never meet your heroes well
I did
and it was awesome
The Avengers were everything I imagined
hello San Francisco Thor Tony check it
out
that's once
yeah obviously figured I'd let you catch
up whoa this just got a whole lot more
interesting let's make this quick
see if you can clear a path on the
bridge
[Music]
shoot not would door what's your status
they're immortal you should have had a
bigger breakfast this morning
Thor thanks for the assist
you've got civilians trapped behind
those barricades understood stay behind
me I'll deal with him
this should be [ __ ]
[Music]
are you hurt no just stop lucky for you
I am mighty Thank You Thor get to safety
big doubt help is on the way
whoa Thunder God that you could have all
the fun
your turn
got it minute that looks pretty
cocky like that
[Music]
it's coming
see quit
not over dark
hey get back here
just got confirmation my shield convoy
was hijacked this morning mr. one of
Fury's boarding three side never read on
Tony those are important okay whatever
allthough sprockets
let's fury kept all my fists back in one
place Rockets are going to destabilize
the fringe yeah I know
I built the damn things
have to should secure the Terrigen
crystal if that thing gets it already on
it
day by cover
all right which one of you be movie
extra shot at me
the convoy is scary but to fight the
field tourniquet furious tracking down
the full manifest
he'll Korea really love being shot at
with my own weapon or keep irrigating ha
hey didn't know you were listening
cities he's running away bike can't
shake the feeling we're playing catch-up
something else going on here
come on down there Tony oh nothing
everything's just peachy just hoping
these guys don't have
they take it back they've got pulsar
test
[Music]
going for a ride cap someone's initiated
the security protocols the chimeras
autopilot has taken over smells like a
heist we're heading back negative
secure the bridge those weapons can't
get into the city copy that you're up
Bruce yeah
[Music]
[Music]
fires on me annoying little guy join me
on my way
no I was thinking today's gonna be one
fan clubs funnel cakes okay Tony
[Music]
we're doing a number on the ball if we
don't take them out
hurry up big guy can't take much more
punishment
big green I got eyes on it Oh bringing
in the Quintus no laughing
[Music]
inventions are dangerous Stark hey those
weapons were meant for the good guys is
that supposed to be a joke not the time
get your heads in the game
cap what's going on over there not sure
nut seems like the reactors
malfunctioning I'm getting strange
readings on the monitors like we're
being pulled to a heat signal in the bay
now that's going to destroy this repeat
that crap I'm having trouble hearing
Matt do you read
all heads the Chimera is under attack
evacuate the civilians
[Music]
you do theory
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
captain we have a problem the reactor
won't stabilize Terrigen molecular
structures are breaking down into a gas
it's extraordinary
if you can't fix the problem and get to
safety
Shepard
if you can hear me the convoy is
transporting a highly lethal sonic
disrupter bombs on enemies intend to
detonate it within the city security
asset at once
no sonic bomb are you kidding me
thought the UN outlawed those years ago
let's have a look shall we
[Music]
now that is an entrance
[Music]
taskmaster
we need to get that detonator that bomb
goes off it could liquify everything
within a ten-mile radius
nor the tables
romertopf from one former SHIELD agent
to another
masters you get a haircut
the bridge is secure
guys I'm getting these three seismic
readings
we'll take this
you know I was hoping to face you
jetpack doesn't matter I have this damn
it hand it over
come and get it
taking your usual note right it's called
photographic reflexes
I've always wondered what it would feel
like to kill an Avenger keep wondering
their cat stolen your weapons from
shield
[Music]
your dance ends now
must be frustrating always one step
behind you're gonna do with it sell it
to the highest bidder I'm after
something much more
where is your investigation left you
you're not the brains behind this and
this smells like distraction I'm done
talking coward
what's the matter don't like surprises
cool
Dalek death can't learn what you can't
see
[Music]
next time take better guess you saw that
coming huh
you think you've won what the hell are
you talking about look around Rome
enough the world will remember this day
the day their heroes failed them
what's happening here
he's collapsing
damnit they played us Steve can you hear
me get the hell out of there
[Music]
screw this
some say they were set up others call
them murderers did the Avengers pose a
danger to society that was the question
Bruce that was the question well we all
lost something that day but that's not
how this story ends
you
[Music]